such an unholy amount of work goes into
making the sinfully good lucifer that
every episode is bursting with rewards
for lucy fans
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan today i'm
revealing 40 behind the scenes secrets
wicked details and fiendishly clever
callbacks that'll make you love lucifer
season 5 even more
spoilers ahead so take care if you're
not all caught up
since it first appeared on lucifer's
hand in the pilot episode
fans have been wondering if there was
more significance to lucy's ring than
just
a simple accessory and season five gave
us the answer
as a show traveled back to the 1940s for
a noir episode featuring maze's mum
lilith the ring's original owner who
gifted it to lucifer when she gave up
her immortality
however the secret behind how it came to
be in the show is much more mundane
shortly before they started filming the
pilots director len wiseman told tom
ellis that he thought there was
something missing from his outfit
that sent ellis rushing back to the
costume department where he found a
random box of jewelry and picked out the
now famous black ring
the ring's last minute addition to the
series even popped up as a little inside
joke in season two when lucy and a
melody were trying to find the final
piece of the flaming sword your ring
i've never seen you without it maybe
that's the key well the key to
completing my ensemble maybe although we
now know the ring stone is from the
garden of eden lucifer says it's only
special because it reminds him of his
old friend lilith
hence why he was so keen to get it back
after candy stole it in season three
sentimental value an especially
intriguing new detail about the ring
that you might have missed is that it
didn't always look like it does today
notice how when we first see it on this
poster of a black gloved lilith the
stone is actually white
and it stays that way until lilith gives
up her immortality breathing her soul or
essence into the ring
causing the stone to change from white
to black something has become quite a
tradition for the show's season
premieres is the appearance of mr set
out [ __ ] and that continues in season 5
where we learn his
real name lee garner and the inspiration
for that name comes from lee garbette
who is the artist behind the recent
lucifer graphic novels
and he also created the comic book
skyward with lucifer co-show runner joe
henderson and we saw trixie reading that
comic in season 4.
this time lee's stuck in his very own
hell loop and in a call back to previous
occasions he ends up sporting very
little
though this time it's his own choice to
wear just speedos
unlike in season 2 where lucifer left
him wearing underpants and a tiara after
catching him robbing a jewelry store
and in season 3 where lucy found him in
the desert driving a stolen truck and
again
left him in his undies season 4 of
course switched things up with lucy
being left pantsless after lee tried to
rob him but ended up with a devilish
gift of cash and gold bars
according to imdb lee is back in the
final episode of part two so it'll be
interesting to see if he gets the
redemptive arc some fans have been
hoping for and if his storyline will
mirror lucy's circumstances again as it
did in part one
the show's writers have been talking
about introducing the character of
michael for a while
hence the season four name drop when
linda and amena deal were working out
what to call their soon-to-be-born
son what about michael no definitely not
michael but according to joe henderson
it was his co-show runner ildi modrovich
who came up with the idea for michael to
be lucifer's twin in the series
because originally season five with just
10 episodes and the show's final season
michael was only going to impersonate
lucifer for part of an episode but when
netflix increased the season order to 16
the showrunners decided to spend a whole
episode with michael pretending to be
lucifer really digging into his devilish
twins life
speaking to backstage magazine tom ellis
revealed that the new challenge of
playing both brothers messed with his
head a bit
given the show's tight filming schedule
using transformative prosthetics to
differentiate michaels off the table
so ellis took inspiration from his
theatre roots and went
old school working out michael's
physicality and voice
he started with some basic concepts and
built from there for example lucifer is
a very flamboyant open character and
shows that in his body language
while michael is the opposite a
closed-off quiet observer
rather than a talker likewise clothing
was crucial to getting into character
with lucifer's sharply tailored suits
contrasting with michael's loose-fitting
tweed jackets and turtlenecks
though it is similar to one of lucifer's
looks in the comics
by the way the scar luce forgives
michael using one of mazakin's blades
after their face-off in the third
episode is a brilliant hat
tip to the comics where maze actually
scores lucifer's face with a blade in a
similar way
another lovely little detail some of you
commented on my other videos is that the
twins are even poles apart when it comes
to drinking with michael preferring
clear spirits like vodka and drinking
with his left hand
whereas lucifer drinks whiskey with his
right hand indeed according to tom ellis
michael hasn't quite got the liver of
lucifer and likes to stay a bit more
lucid and aware of what's going on
when it came to michael's voice ellis
went for an american accent to help
distinguish between the characters
and that's especially interesting
because initially before the show's very
first season when ellis is working out
how best to play lucifer he actually
tried that accent out but felt that lucy
always ended up sounding like a jerk
however with an english accent he found
lucifer could get away with saying
all sorts of terrible things and still
come across as rather charming
oh how's your ex detected douche which
is why switching to that original
american accent makes perfect sense for
playing his villainous twin michael
how do you like the mess i made samuel
and fun fact
ellis has a twin sister in real life and
coincidentally her name is
lucy the payback board lucifer creates
as he plots his revenge on dan for
shooting him is full of hilarious
in-jokes and callbacks to previous
episodes from dan's time undercover as a
surfer and actor kevin alejandro's own
love of catching a wave
to the action movie franchise weaponizer
which dan adores
personal fave weaponizer for the last
house
to the recurring topic of dan's love of
pudding and the fact that lucifer thinks
that eating dan's dessert
isn't punishment enough and judging by
what lucy wants to do with dan's
bracelet it looks like there'll be no
more bracelet bros
bracelet brush for the win oh and
there's even a little shout out to queer
eye netflix's life makeover show
ella thinks of lucifer as a brother so
she's really annoyed that he not only
failed to say goodbye when he left la
but that he also didn't let her know
when he returned
so when he turns up at the team's latest
crime scene ella gives him a piece of
her mind and a thump with her shoe which
is a little nod to the latina heritage
of both her character
and actress amy garcia who plays her and
the tradition of whipping off a shoe or
chankler to reprimand or discipline
someone norma says
no mess of course that isn't actually
lucifer it's his twin brother michael
but
ella doesn't know that and when it came
to episode 8
its writer chris rafferty also worked
with the show's art department
specifically to sneak in some fun for
the show's die hard fans
by adding some cunning callbacks to
previous episodes that he wrote
when lucy and ella visit the whisper
killer's latest crime scene there's some
cleverly titled film posters on the wall
first up is a bad day to die which has
the tagline her time is ticking to find
the cure
mirroring the season 2 episode 13 title
and plot of a good
day to die where lucy returns to hell to
try and find the antidote to a poison
that's quickly killing chloe
and there's another easter egg to that
same season 2 episode via a door that's
labeled 213.
then there's a poster for monster-ish a
shout-out to another season 2 episode
called monster about a murder at a
zombie-themed wedding
and as a priest walks into a barn a play
on the season 1 episode a priest walks
into a bar
where lucifer met the priest frank
lawrence who's one of the few humans in
the series who figured out lucy's true
identity
your father has a plan god finally makes
his first
on-screen appearance in the mid-season
finale with dennis hayes but in the role
and that bit of casting means this isn't
just a reunion
for our favorite celestial family but
also for hayes but and a melody actor
d.b woodside
who previously worked together on the
action drama 24
where they played brothers each of whom
became president of the united states
in fact when it came to casting god
woodside actually suggested haze but to
the lucifer showrunners who according to
ew had him at the top of their list of
possible actors for the part
two real-life women who greatly inspired
leslie and brandt's portrayal of maze on
the show are grace jones and eartha kitt
so it's no coincidence that one of the
songs performed by her mother lilith was
made famous by none other than earth a
kid
in fact brandt told the spectrum lounge
podcast that kits i want to be evil
and someone to watch over me memorably
sung by ella fitzgerald were chosen to
pay homage to two black american icons
as well as arthur kitt the episode's
writer ayanna white
also looked to billy holliday for
inspiration for lilith's character
as for film noir the show's creative
team chose that not only for its links
with detective stories but also because
it fits the old hollywood elegant style
of tom ellis's lucifer so well
and adding to the show's tributes the
episode frames its tale of lilith in
1940s new york with what the showrunners
have called their princess bride moment
as lucifer narrates the story of his
manhattan adventures to trixie who
interrupts with questions and comments
wait hold it crying out loud hold it
hold it what is this
when you look back over season five so
far as a whole there are several motifs
and themes which occur strongly
throughout
and one of the most intriguing is the
motif of mirroring or doubles there's
the obvious example of lucy and his twin
michael
and as the way maze decides to dress and
act exactly like ella
then the whole of episode 3 is insanely
meta
about a murder on the set of diablo a tv
procedural that mirrors lucifer and
chloe's working relationship
has doubles of all our favourites and
also mirrors the netflix show we're
watching
on top of that the dead showrunner is a
spitting image of lucifer's
co-showrunner joe henderson
whose own real-life office and writer's
room double as the ones in the fictional
show
and the fourth episode takes episodes
three's doubling to a whole new level
giving the shows cast new roles to play
that reflect their usual ones so
therapist
linde is a bartender detective chloe's a
p.i
dan is the super douchey willy the
sausage prince and
lilith maze's mother her spitting image
though
neither of them would ever admit it and
regarding maize there's a parallel this
season between how she feels abandoned
by her mother and linda's situation with
her daughter who she gave up for
adoption
even the season's secret serial killer
pete has his own
mirror in the copycat killer klumpsky as
for chloe she gets to mirror lucifer's
mojo superpower
and if you'd like to know the true cause
of that and also why lucifer's
invulnerability changed in season 5
tap here to watch my lucifer and chloe
powers video or follow the link in the
video description
so who were your favorite characters
this season and did you spot
any other interesting details leave your
thoughts in the comments below
and if you enjoyed this a thumbs up and
a share are hugely appreciated
next tap left for my lucifer playlist
with a full breakdown of the mid-season
finale predictions and theories for part
two and season six
plus more amazing easter eggs you might
have missed in the fifth season
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers